all right guys
bang bang i've got sam here with us
thanks so much for doing this man
yeah i mean thanks for having me
absolutely all right so
uh i think that you are uh one of the
most fascinating people in all of crypto
and
many people don't know your story so
let's just start with
uh kind of where you grew up uh where
you went to school and then how you got
into
uh into crypto yeah i grew up in the san
francisco bay area
um on a stanford campus and had a you
know really nice sort of quiet
uh you know suburban upbringing so to
speak um
and i yeah i mean it is served a good
early
life um parents are both law professors
and i sort of thought you know maybe i
was gonna do math or physics or
i don't know it wasn't the plans were
sort of very non-specific
uh you know sort of like select
whichever subject i was doing best at in
school and like that's what i'm gonna do
you know
um and i and so i went to mit
and i quickly learned there i wasn't
gonna be a physicist i mean
like that's your least favorite things
that i've done were trying to do physics
research
so that's you know that that wasn't
going to be the answer um
but that doesn't sort of answer the
question of what the answer will be
you know what i will do and i
you know spent some time in college
trying to think about what i could do
that sort of have the most impact
and ended up at i thinking about how i
could
donate you know as much as i could and
that sort of led me to quant finance
um so i was a trader at jane street
capital for
about three years in new york um which
is a blast and he's
really had fun there it's really really
nice um and then
you know sort of after three years or so
i had a
you know sort of a fork in the path of
like it you know
am i gonna sort of do this for the rest
of my life or am i gonna try and do
other stuff and
it's a tough call i really liked it um
but sort of felt like i wanted to
explore i wanted to try other things
i want to see what
you know that that maybe there is huge
upside doing other things too
and so that sort of you know i left and
shortly thereafter i mean sure checked
out crypto markets which is late 2017.
and i mean markets are completely insane
then like is
and the arbitrages were just gigantic
and does serve my background and so
that's sort of how i ended up in crypto
all right
so when you're in school uh obviously
you're smart you got a bunch of smart
classmates uh everyone is kind of going
into all these different things
uh the uh kind of classic tale is uh
people gravitate towards wall street
because uh that's where you can make the
most money
but yeah i think one of the most
interesting parts about your story is uh
this idea of
how do i make as much money to give it
all away so maybe let's just start with
yeah kind of where did that idea come
from um
and kind of how did you formulate you
know a strategy to go do this
yeah so i mean it's sort of like a
wandering path to get there
um started with you know what can i do
that i'll have impact
went through a bunch of random things i
you know
went uh got into animal welfare um
thought about global poverty and stuff
uh ultimately
met a group of people who were thinking
about some similar things to
the effective altruism community um
sometime around my
my junior year sophomore year i guess of
college
and they sort of said like suggested
like you know hey
if this is what you're thinking like you
know obviously there are a lot of things
you can do but one thing you should ask
is like if there's some charity you
think is cool
like would they rather have you know you
working for them or you donating money
to them like
which and obviously again for different
people it's different but like
you know sort of given my background it
sort of seemed like
well actually like you know quantitative
skills are pretty good fit
for uh for at least what what nowadays
is
is often lubricative careers um and i
had some friends who had interned at
jane street said
good things about it and so i just sort
of decided i don't know
let's you know try and you know try try
interviewing see how it is
see if it seems like a good fit and and
and sort of really like the
interview and it wasn't so much i like
calculated out every path it was like
this is the highest dp
which to be clear maybe i should have
done uh but but i didn't instead i
i was sort of like oh wow i had no idea
what he's doing and now all of a sudden
this seems like really high
value like seems like i could
potentially donate a lot of money this
way and that seems great
got it and so that's a very unique way
of viewing the world
right um kind of talk through uh
how you think about it from you have
seen money to live
right yeah there's a story recently uh
there was a uh
i think a multi-billionaire uh who
basically had amassed a fortune of like
eight billion dollars
uh and he successfully given it all away
he literally lives in like a
shoebox san francisco apartment says
that he's incredibly happy
uh and his entire life goal was to give
away his fortune um and he's now done
that
uh but he amassed a fortune and then
gave it away
are you kind of as you're making money
giving it away or is this so let's get
as much money as possible it's a good
question and
i sort of think if you can do it the
ideal thing
in some ways there's a lot of activity
about this is sort of the
actual answer and here are sort of two
ways to think about it right one is like
well if you amass money you can grow
that money
you know and like then you can give away
way more than if you'd been giving away
the whole time
because you know you get interest on
that money one way or another
the other way of thinking about it is
sure well also the charities could have
been doing things with that in the
meantime and you know
they could have been saving people's
lives who have been contributing to the
world and like
doesn't that have some compounding
effects too and sort of the answer is
yeah actually most things that are
really high impact have compounding
effects
the compounding sort of part of what
makes some high impact and you have to
sort of think about which is bigger
and so i think you know part of how i
think buddies like given where i am
right now
you know what's what's sort of
relatively larger
and i mean i think for people who are in
crypto right now it's not going to shock
them to hear that like
returns on capital can be pretty
significant and
and and you know i think that you just
have to look like what's happened in d5
over the last you know four months to
see that like
that's gonna outrip a lot of things um
and so part of my answer is like well if
you think you have unusually way
you know unusually good ways to grow
money which you probably do if you're
in the business of growing money uh then
that's like a decent argument towards
george sort of growing it over time and
then donate on the other hand
and these a lot of people would say this
and i think they have a real point
like yeah sure i've heard that one
before you know like like
person says oh yeah don't worry like
this is you know i'm i'm one of the good
guys
um and and i think that that's like
you know that that's a real word that
you can have about other people and it's
where you can have about yourself
even if you're not you know even if
you're not selfish it's a sort of
drifting way
forgetting about why you got there in
the first place
and so what i actually do and i'm not
saying this is a perfect thing like
there's
things pulling in all directions here
but you know i sort of
give away enough each year that it's
sort of a real amount
that's a significant amount and that it
sort of keeps me honest
and and you know keeps me i i yeah sort
of
he keeps me um keeps reminding me of
like
why i did this in the first place keeps
me in touch with people who are thinking
about it keeps me in the loop about
things
i can do keeps me thinking about what i
can do with money
and and so even if it's not like most of
my money each year even if
a lot of it is you know the goal is to
compound it and give it later
um i there's a lot of good that that i
think you can
there's a lot of good you can do now and
i think that there's a lot of value to
at least giving something away to keep
yourself honest
absolutely and so let's talk about what
you've done
to uh grow wealth right so you've got
kind of two separate things you've got
ftx and then you've got alabita research
uh jane street is a pretty legit shop
right that's a pretty good job um
when you decided to leave did you know
that you were gonna go
uh into crypto or was this more of you
left and then as you were exploring
things to do crypto kind of caught your
eye
yeah like when i left there were like 12
things i i started didn't know exactly
what i
can do and actually i was like gonna try
working at a charity it was one of one
of the things that added an effective
altruist journey and
and i think that like sort of there are
all these paths and they're so hard to
think about right like
you know here's one thing that like you
know and there's so many things you
think about you're like oh boy
who the hell knows how valuable that is
you know like you campaign for policies
that you think are good
or for politicians who think will
implement them or
you could go work on climate change you
go work on third world developing
diseases
some of these turn out to be somewhat
analyzable
like you can look at sort of a classic
example as like how many lives per
dollar can you save
donating to third world health charities
and you can actually ballpark that right
you can just do trials right
you can go into a village you can give
malaria trade bed nets
um and and see what happens on malaria
rates and there's a lot of complications
but like
you know that's sort of an inanalyzable
thing but many of these things are
really hard
to ballpark you know if you're gonna
like how much impact can you have on the
world as a journalist the answer has to
be a lot
like clearly they have impact on the
world but it's really hard to think
about
how much and what the right thing to do
is so sort of my thought was like
boy there are all these things i want to
try doing some of them i can sort of
think about some of them i have a lot of
trouble estimating
and just going to be hard to know how
big they could get until i try
and and so that was sort of the thought
was try a bunch of things and like
see what sticks got it and so
when you eventually discover crypto uh
was it literally just the arbitrage
opportunity
uh was just so big that like it was
hitting you over the head and saying you
have to go do this or was there other
things that uh that kind of dragged you
in
yeah i mean that was the first thing
that dragged me in was just you know
looking at literally
losers looked at coin market cap you
know i clicked on bitcoin
i saw these numbers like those aren't
the same numbers you know like i see a
list of exchanges and prices
and the prices are different and like
and that's not like complicated
arbitrage
or so i thought i was like literally
that like nothing that simple ever
happens
you know but the numbers they weren't
even a little bit different you know
they're like five ten percent different
and and so sort of my first thought was
like that's fake like i don't know why
yet
but that's fake that can't be real and
and they sort of investigated and the
answer is
half of it was fake you know but half
those exchanges were not real
but half them actually were and there
were some real arbitrages
sprinkled in with the fake ones um and
the real challenge
back in 2017 was not finding a good
trade it was being able to do it um
and the operational setup involved in it
was just
massive okay explain this because i
think a lot of people don't understand
what we're talking about like
super simple arbitrary arbitrage is
basically just
you go to one exchange you buy bitcoin
you move it on to another exchange you
sell it
there's literally two different prices
and you take the difference
exactly this isn't some weird derivative
you're not thinking about interest rates
literally coinbase and bitstamp
have different prices for bitcoin right
like that shouldn't be too hard
so what happens i'll explain may be one
of the more complicated
simple arbitrages um
and because i think sort of rolls into
one all the different things you have to
think about
and this is uh the japan arb so
i was uh you know late 2017 early 2018
japanese bitcoins are just training like
five to 15 percent higher than american
bitcoins
meaning you go on bitflyer or
coinchecker
uh bitbank or one of the japanese
exchanges
and you know it's an 11 000 bitcoin and
you go on coinbase and it's a 10 000
bitcoin as it's sort of like you know
there there's there's an arbitrage
and that was big there's a billion
dollars a day trading on each side so if
you could do it
sort of seem like maybe you could do it
big which is pretty exciting it's also
like 10
a day i don't know it is a lot you know
so then you try and do it and you fail
for 12 reasons
and like so many reasons it's over
determined so what happens well
first of all you realize you don't have
a coinbase account there's a three month
waiting list
um you realize you don't have a bitfire
account and you have to be japanese to
get one and there's a three month
waiting list
um you get those then you wire a hundred
dollars as a test transfer to your
coinbase account
and your bank shuts down your bank
account because they don't like crypto
um then you realize that you can only
withdraw to a japanese bank account
from bipflyer and you need to be
japanese to have a japanese bank account
um so okay you get a new bank account
you find a japanese person
or company or something now you have a
japanese bank account then you realize
you have three thousand dollar a day
withdrawal limits on coinbase and again
there's a three-month waiting list
to get your withdrawal limits raised um
then you realize
that uh your japanese banking can't do
international wire transfer so it's not
clear how you're getting the money out
of japan
and she's like you go through so many
things here and thing after thing after
thing is like i guess i have to learn
how to start a company in a foreign
country
and hire people there and get a bank
account and lawyer and then you go to do
a wire transfer in japan
you realize you don't speak japanese and
that's going to be a problem because
their website doesn't they're no online
there weren't you you couldn't do it
online you had to go okay also not in
japan
and i don't speak japanese but if you in
person in a branch of a japanese bank
so there are two more problems they have
to solve somehow and you finally
get someone there and and the banker is
like what the [ __ ] is this like this is
definitely money laundering like no no
it's not it's arbitrage like
no you don't understand you're wiring
millions of dollars
every day from crypto to an overseas
bank account in a different name
like this is like that's it's the
sketchiest thing you can be doing it's
always in the same direction it's not
like you're
moving it back it's all only going one
way you're like no
you don't understand on the back end i
got bitcoins going from gdax
to bitflyer and like i didn't understand
any of that but this checks all the
boxes of a sketchy transaction
and also remember you don't speak
japanese and they don't speak english
and so now you go hire japanese lawyers
not to like not to like for a court case
or something you hire them
to go talk to a banker because like
they're like a trustworthy person who
could speak the line
so it's just like it was it's months and
months of setup that went into like
all of these different pieces and the
problem is if you have all but one
you have nothing right what you end up
with you end up with a ton of japanese
yen pooled in a bank account in japan
that you can't do anything with and it's
not like you're cycling and arbitraging
every day just sitting there
so it's like you need to put you know 12
pieces together to a single
round of arbitrage so that that's sort
of the problem that you've run into is
just like
you know it's crypto is incredibly
logistically complicated because
it's decentralized and like you think
about well how about how about normal
finance what happens the answer is
all u.s exchange is clear under the same
clearing symbol with a centralized
clearinghouse
you store everything with a centralized
custodian um
or clearing firm who also stores all
your money in and has connected to all
the exchanges for you and could do
foreign currency transactions and
everything
like just it's all in one place you know
but in crypto because of
decentralization
one of the sort of side effects of this
is that if you have to do something that
touches a lot of different
companies you have to separately figure
out logistics for every single one
and so as you're doing this uh the name
of uh the company
is really interesting to me so alameda
research uh the research component uh
is not what i think most people would
expect a you know
basically trading shop um and so tell
the story i'll meet i've heard where
that comes from so explain that one
because that's
cool and then the research what was that
the logic there yeah so alameda uh
you know uh started out in berkeley
california
which is in alameda county um so that
that's where aluminium comes from
research um 10 if it came from the fact
that there is some research there
there's like
you run studies you know and like one
example of this would be
you want to figure out uh arbitrages are
simple when i describe them the way i
described them at least to think about
but let's say that you're in the middle
of a market move it's like a two second
long market move and everything
every exchange is reporting a different
bitcoin price and you want to figure out
if there's a trade to do but
all the exchanges they did is lagging so
you don't know if it's really an
arbitrage
or if this is just like one exchange is
pre-move and one is post move
but you can't actually trade on the free
move once it's post move now
um and you might have to do a lot of
statistical studies and a lot of data
analysis
uh to try and figure out what's actually
going on there
so there there is some research in it um
but
that's not really where the name com
came from
really where the name come from we're
we're trying to think of an a name for
the company and
we're not good at naming things i mean
it's just like a weakness of
i'm not good at it i don't like
but we needed name like we sort of like
at some point our corporate development
is blocked on having a name
and what were the criteria um
the criteria were not like you know
bitcoin arbitrage trading shop
what variant of that should we use sir
took a step back we're like all right
we want a bank account and if we're
bitcoin arbitrage trading shop founded
by a bunch of 20 year olds
if that's the name of our company we're
not getting our bank account like
the compliance department's gonna take
one look at that and just like
that that's it right answer like all
right what's like
what's what name is never going to give
us grief you know what name
is not going to stop us from being able
to do anything like research
no one doesn't like research you know no
one's like i don't know research i don't
know if we can deal with that
that's where it came from it's
completely an offensive name
that is an amazing story
so give us an overview of kind of what
you guys are doing today right so you uh
you guys are based in hong kong i
believe
uh yeah kind of what exactly does
alameda research
entail yeah it's i
the core way to think about it is um
it's a liquidity fighter and what does
that mean
a crypto liquidity fighter what does
that mean well
one of the things it means is like you
know if it does arbitrage and
what's the connection between those well
if there's buyers on bitstamp and
sellers on coinbase of bitcoin
then you provide liquidity to the
sellers on coinbase by putting out bids
you provide
liquidity to the buyers on bitstamp by
putting out offers you make money by
doing arbitrage
and you help tighten spreads and you
help keep you know keep things in line
and provide actual coins for people
buying dollars for people to sell into
so that's sort of like the classic you
know simple like liquidity fighting by
arbitrage connection um and that that's
a lot of what alameda does but
but increasingly as crypto branches out
it does too into all the wacky ways that
crypto demands liquidity and so
you know then you get to futures and
derivatives right like flying liquidity
on futures
you know if you want to go trade on i
you know let's say that you want to go i
i don't know
pick your favorite exchange with future
is right you want to go
to to to finance or wobby or bitmex or
or whatever and you want to buy a
bitcoin future
i someone has to be on there they're on
the other side sort of keeping it
at about the price of a bitcoin and so
that's sort of another thing it's like
you know futurist versus spot arbitrage
um but then there's sort of you know
there's there's fiat arbitrage right so
keeping japanese and u.s exchanges in
line with each other
is there another branch of this um and
recently i mean what's been
you know what's a thing that cryptocert
needed liquidity friday to in the last
few months well it's defined
that's where all the activity is you
know and so it's like frying liquidity
in all the wacky ways
that you can buy or sell comp you know
like
it's not just like finance to coinbase
liquidity there's also like you know
unit swap and all the borrow lending
protocols that have it
and uh and and otc and
and then there's like yield farming and
and so basically wherever there's
trading activity in crypto um
there is you know there's sort of a
place to private liquidity and there's a
place to make money
by doing arbitrage if there's sort of
enough demand and not enough supply
and so you know what alameda is sort of
spending his time on
varies for months month depending on
what crypto's funniest time thinking
about
got it and then where does ftx come in
yeah so you know alameda had been going
for about a year this is like late 2018
and um i mean something had been clear
from the beginning
was that exchanges make a lot of money
in crypto um
seems like a good business to be in the
product
there's a lot of complications on the
outside but if you think about the
really core product of like
a matching engine that is not that
complicated
like that is sort of like well you place
a bid and you place an offer
if they cross then you match them you
know that that's like
and so we're sort of like okay like we
can do that that's not that hard
that's a lot easier than the bots we're
building and they seem to be doing quite
well
um but the problem is that a lot of
other people can do that too and have
done that
and we don't know any customers we don't
have a network
we don't like so yeah we could launch
yet another bitcoin tether exchange
and hope people used it and no one would
that that's sort of like where we were
for a while and where we were stuck on
um and what sort of finally got it out
of that
that right to some extent was i
a few things happening at once i moved
to hong kong and
i had a lot of meetings with people here
almeida built out an otc desk and i
built
a networking crypto from that um so all
of a sudden we had some institutional
connections
had some personal connections um
and then the other thing was all the
derivatives exceeded you sort of [ __ ]
the bet at the same time
and um and it's sort of like you know
there's
the overload problems there are massive
clawbacks everywhere it's like hundreds
of millions of dollars a year being lost
to this
and so it's sort of like okay like a
derivatives exchange is
is harder there's more that goes into it
there's a risk engine
margin leverage the matching engine's
harder because of the risk engine
um a lot of the players right now seem
to be having a lot of trouble with it
there's a ton of volume going in in them
and now with a bit of a network
and that was sort of enough to make us
feel like we had a plausible path
forward there
um and so you know started building out
ftx sort of late 2018 early 2019
and i and yeah went live
spring of 2019 and at the very beginning
sort of an experiment of like
we think we can build a good product
like that we think we can do
um is that enough like
a good product and a little bit of a
network
you know can that become a big exchange
and the answer is no that's not enough
to become a big exchange that fails
um but if you take those and then you
just like push a lot
you you do a ton of work at everything
from
recruiting users everything from
retail customers to large institutions
um
to making a ton of ui changes to doing
customer support
um and all the random
crazy things that come up that you have
to deal with um
and then you just push really hard on
building out a user base and network
while simultaneously building out the
product
then yeah you can do it and
um and so that's very few of what we've
been doing over the last year with ftx
and it's you know it's i grown to
roughly the fifth biggest exchange uh
which is which is pretty cool
um it's still sort of derivatives first
in that like you know the majority of
its volume and sort of it's like
most well-known products or derivatives
um but you know it has spot markets as
well tokenized products fiat
and and a bunch of other things
got it and all of this has been
self-funded or you guys have race
capital outside
have you built all this yeah so alameda
was a combination
of uh self-funding and lines of credit
from like friends and family and stuff
um to bootstrap which was uh sort of a
high wire act for a little while
um but set us up really well for the
future um
i by the way hold on a second that's a
great way to say you raised no outside
capital
that's right yeah almighty has never
raised any outside capital and
and that's sort of important to it
because anyone who has investors
is aware of the pain of having investors
you know and i
it just even if they're the best
investors in the world there's a pain
associated with it you know
um and just to give one trivial example
let's say you want to open up a bank
account
for your company you go to the bank and
they're like we have a signature of all
the owners
and you're like no i am not all of the
owners some of them are thousands of
miles away they're like great come back
when you have their signatures
and that doesn't sound that bad because
you email them you're like please sign
this
um but all of a sudden you sort of like
double the work it takes to do a lot of
administrative active actions and once
you do that
a lot of them like it just slows down a
bunch of things and
not having that's been really great for
alameda um
ftx started out the same way um although
there was
ftt a token sale um
but uh but since then ftx has taken
outside investors
and so ftx it's still majority
internally owned but
uh but does have outside capital got it
um you mentioned uh d5 earlier and so
uh i think what most people are
wondering is just
you have a fantastic uh trading business
with alameda
you've got a fantastic uh exchange
business with ftx
uh quite simply just what the hell are
you doing playing around with all this
defy stuff
talk through just how you see defy and
kind of what i'll call a lot of kind of
like the financial engineering and
experimentation and kind of all the
wackiness that's going on there
in light of the greater kind of crypto
uh industry how do you
view d5 and then we can talk about some
of the things you're doing there
yeah so i
it i sort of stumbled into it at the
beginning um
and you know a lot of where this came
from was that's where the winds were
blowing
that's where crypto attention was
turning
and it's really important for ftx
um to be responsive to that like
it's you know it's three months earlier
everyone was asking about options
and and wanting us to improve our
options offering no one's asked about
options in the last three months
like no one cares anymore probably they
will get in four months you know
and and when was the last time you heard
about derebit right
like probably like april um
that doesn't mean it's dead it means
like you know in six months maybe
derebit's all people are going to talk
about it again like it's sort of like
you know derek's best known for its
options and so but so anyway you know
one of one of what we're trying to do
with ftx is
is to be uh
to be offering customers sort of
whatever they want
you know when they want it as much as we
can and i
you know
what that means is basically like well
i it means that when
the world's moving to d5 we try and
offer d5 products
and it's a little bit tricky um it's
like you could do some of that with ftx
right like we listed compound markets
sure you know you can list defy tokens
on the exchange
i mean we're sort of one of the first
exchanges to start doing that
um because we got a lot of interest and
demand in it
um but there's a problem like the
problem is that
like ftx is not defined it's it's
centralized like it just is
and what that meant was like anything
ftx
action was that's where customers demand
was
um you know we wanted to be able to fill
that
and you know so
pivoting at ftx as much as made sense
for its product
um i sort of did a deeper dive in
and i basically came out with with two
main thoughts
the first is that a lot of the products
had serious
shortcomings um but the second was that
there's some really cool [ __ ] there
and you know some things that sort of
i first of all just found like the
on-chain governance
uh the idea of that really cool and
really powerful and sort of surprisingly
sleek and like
i sort of like surprised that that just
worked i could make it just work
although obviously theoretically you
could
um but second of all i think the thing
that really drawn me over time was
composability
and if you if you ask me like what the
biggest advantage of defy is
it's that it's composability it's the
fact that
if you have if two different people make
two different products indeed buy
you can glue them together and and what
that means is like
you know let's say that you take a dex
and you take a borrow lending protocol
um you know so you take like
you swap plus compound or something like
that you know sushi swap plus alpha or
you know whatever you want like
um you can in one transaction
do a margin trade on the decks and the
way you do it is i mean you sort of like
get the leverage from the bar lending
protocol and the
deltas from from from the decks you know
basically you send one thing to our
lending protocol
use it for another thing send it back to
the decks and buy the first thing with
it
and now you've gotten levered in it um
but the really cool thing about that is
that you can just do it
by gluing those two together even though
they're totally separate projects
and if you imagine doing that i
you know you imagine doing that in in
centralized finance you can do it but
it's a hell of a lot
more annoying and harder like you're
ping-ponging between multiple exchanges
you have to deal with withdrawal limits
and withdrawal
times liquidation on both sides and like
it it you know you sort of have to have
like an automated trading system set up
to be able to really do it realistically
whereas in d5 you can just glue all the
[ __ ] together and that that's just
really cool
and it's super powerful and it means
that like you can have
a lot of people working on a community
together and all building useful things
for it
and not independent things where just
the best one wins
like things that that add together um
so anyway that's that's sort of like
waste
what sort of struck me is like one of
the most powerful things about d5 um but
also just
yeah the products were not were like a
little underwhelming
um and so recently you talked a little
bit about
uh kind of this like toxic defy
environment
so kind of talk through like it feels
like there's uh
a lot of potential with uh the direction
the technology is going
then there's all kinds of craziness with
like the people the projects the
tribalism
like just talk through that a little bit
yeah it's um
i mean it it it's it's weird because
it's in some sense the most
in some sense it's a lot more
cooperative
than cfi is like people are all bullying
together
but in some sense it's also a lot more
toxic and
at least in places and i don't know
there's sort of been a bunch of things
that sort of combine to do that but
but just sort of throwing some of them
out there like
i i
one thing obviously is protocols like
there are big believers in a lot of
protocols
um you know maxis is often feel like
none of it's quite derogatory
some people i think use it derogatory
some people use it non-derogatorily
but you know bitcoin maximalists
ethereum maximalists
um you know i'm sure that there's some
maximalists for
you know pretty much every project
although you know those those are the
two biggest
communities by far um uh and
i you know they don't get along so well
they don't get along so well with other
protocols and that's sort of independent
of whether they're right like you know
i mean they can't all be right like max
was for two different communities it's a
little hard for those
to both be right at least in the strong
version of them but
um but you know maybe one card but
but one way or another like there's a
lot of flaming that goes on
from adherence to one community towards
other communities
and other projects again which isn't to
say like one of them might be right but
one way or another there's a lot of
toxicity there um
there's also um yield farming is weird
it's
i mean i i so i sort of i don't know i i
i did the math and was like actually
kind of surprised at like
how legit some of it was in that like
it's
i think there's a version of yield
farming which which is actually
sensible sort of which is basically like
you build a valuable product
and want customers
and sort of and want people to build on
it and stuff and
the deal you make is you're going to
hand out most the value of it you're
just going to drop the token on its
users in order to get other people to
use it and incentivize to build on it
um
and yeah you give them yield for that
and
that vision is not crazy and
if you think that defy is worth tens of
billions of dollars
then it could be a fair bit of value
that you get out of this
all right so i want i want to uh take a
second for you to explain
exactly how this works because i think
there's a lot of people who listen to
this
who uh they've heard of yield farming
like the terminology
they have how it works so kind of just
walk us through exactly what's happening
when people are doing this
yeah uh so first i'll just say
mechanically here's
there's a lot of different versions of
it um i'm just gonna like
talk about sort of a really simplified
version of it and you can put as many
knobs on it as you want
but at its heart what is it you build a
product
and uh it's a product people can use
um you know maybe it's a borrow lending
protocol maybe it's a dex
um whatever i
let's for now say that it's a borrow
lending protocol that's where this all
started
um and what you say is all right i want
a lot of people to be borrowing and
lending for my protocol right
and what do i mean by borrow lending
protocol something like compound or ave
where you can basically it's
you know put in ether and take out usdt
or whatever
you know there's sort of like a bunch of
of accepted tokens and you can lend
some of them to the protocol and you can
borrow other coins against it
um and then other people can borrow the
coins you're lending out
and you're paying each other interest
for this um
i so um
see you want to incentivize growth in
your project
and you want to incentivize people to
start using it
building on it integrating with it um
and so what you do is you say all right
first of all all the revenue is going to
go to this token
you know you create a token it's the
equivalent of it you know an exchange
shop and a protocol token whatever
um and you say all the revenue for my
projects going to this token you know
with compounders comp
um and what we're going to do is for the
next three months we're just going to
every day airdrop a thousand tokens
on everyone who's using the platform
which is proportionately however much
you're using it so however much you're
borrowing plus lending out
you know that's how many points you get
and then this thousand these thousand
comp tokens
just get divided evenly between all
those people
um and i
what happens then is you know a lot of
people go to use your protocol because
they want to get your token
for free so they start borrowing or
lending
um and they get your token you give up
most of your tokens
or some or i mean it depends on the
project
um and they get yield and what yield
means here is basically like you know
they're putting up
you know a thousand dollars of capital
and every day
they're getting one dollar of your of of
the token air drops you know
and so they're getting 10 bips a day you
know on their capital
just literally putting it there and
lending it out and the yield is coming
in the form of the protocol token that's
being airdropped on them
and the vision is now all of a sudden
all these people whose borrow lending
protocols have your token
they want yours to win they want to
build on yours they're aligned with you
um
and they provided value by
providing liquidity to your protocol you
know by providing coins for people to
borrow
and so all that's great and helps you
out you help them out you're aligned
that that's the theory behind it and i'm
sort of like
you know taking sort of like the
positive light the optimal version of
this and ignoring all the bad [ __ ] that
happens
okay so when people are doing this uh
just to summarize
the whole idea is to incentivize users
to adopt
my product or my network over another
one and therefore basically i pay
uh some rate of return for them adopting
that
right that's right over another one or
over just doing nothing
but yeah okay the interest i think
is uh or the return on some of these i
think is where
uh kind of especially people who come
with the traditional water like wait
what is going on
because yeah you know the return can be
a thousand percent
right or you know these crazy crazy
numbers so kind of talk through a little
bit
uh i'm assuming that you you believe
that like that's not very sustainable
and will kind of get commoditized down
but but maybe not
yeah that's a really good point and and
and that is where a lot of the [ __ ]
starts to get weird is that
when someone says that they have an
interest-bearing product for you you
know
like let's just say give it a crypto
right so it's like i got some bonds you
know
they're like i don't know corporate
bonds or something and they're gonna pay
you interest each year
like great what's the interest of like
six percent a year sure like all right
you know that's a number that i find
plausible you know i'm sort of like
is that better or worse than putting in
the stock market like i don't know maybe
it's a little
worse a little safer or whatever
anything between like one and 15 percent
a year
is sort of like normal land and crypto
interest rates are higher
um there are a lot of ways to think
about this but just generally crypto
interest rates are like
20 a year roughly so in crypto you have
something that pays 20
a year and it's actually kind of
reasonable you know
there are a lot of people who pay 20 a
year for capital there are a lot of
people who loan capital at 20
a year whatever um
so okay anywhere between like five and
thirty percent is like plausible in
crypto but as you said some of these are
a thousand and a thousand
is equivalent like it's just like that's
a ridiculous number right like like no
one ever pays you a thousand percent a
year
right and why is that well first of all
everyone would do it
also why are they paying you so much
money where is it coming from
like this way too much like you could
you could have said
a hundred and i would have been amazed
at it like a thousand
like that that's ridiculous so it's sort
of your thoughts like this has to be a
scam
like this is the like you know send one
bitcoin to us and we'll send you two
back
type scam right um and
and what's actually happening there is
i well mechanically what happened was
yeah they're air dropping the tokens on
the users and just do the math
you know they're like giving away half
of all their protocol tokens the next
two weeks and uh
that's a quarter billion dollars worth
of tokens are given away
and you know there's optimistically
going to be
a billion dollars locked in this
protocol
using it so then you have 25 over a
couple weeks that's where you get these
insane numbers from
and there are sort of a few ways of
thinking about this
the optimistic way is like yeah time
horizons are shrinking
they want their protocol to do well soon
so they're
they're like we're not going to give it
to the next you know pass out these
tokens over the next two years let's
just do over the next two weeks
why wait so yeah it's a ton of yield for
two weeks
if we're giving away mostly value the
protocols to users and that's that's the
trade we're making in return for getting
a lot of users
and i it's a little weird because people
should be putting a [ __ ] ton of money in
like that should be drawing
a hundred billion dollars out to make
their return more reasonable right
like um that's sort of the optimistic
take the pessimistic take is like
it's a scam and or it's not
really a thousand percent a year and
what does that mean
here's an easy way to give it an insane
yield you just take a token
and every day you double the number of
tokens you just mint another
entire new set of them and air dropping
on the current token holders so yeah
you're given 100 today
but obviously the price is crashing like
it's just a hyperinflating token you're
not
actually giving out value there and so
another thing that might be happening
is that the tokens price is actually
crashing just as fast as it's paying you
so you don't make money for for doing
this um
or maybe it's a scam they're gonna steal
all your money somehow
and so those are sort of the pessimistic
takes are these just like the new icos
yeah i mean they're not exactly the new
icos like
i i mean there there's differences and
everyone will
come up with like their own
you know sort of reasons for why they're
different
and not not structurally but just in the
sense of
you know using a new mechanism for
capital markets and incentives and and
kind of
um you know acquiring users you know
icos was one
version this seems just like a second
yeah and it's not passing judgment on
good or bad
it just is what it is right and i think
in the end my answer to you is
closer to yes than no you know my answer
is sort of like
yeah these kind of are the new icos like
that's actually not a bad way to think
about it
and whatever there's you know a lot else
going on there obviously it's not
that but but yeah at its heart he's
there a lot of resemblances to icos
and it also feels like um there's this
game going on like in my opinion uh
there's people who
uh i'm probably closer with that would
say you know bitcoin is the only thing
nothing else matters all this other
stuff is you know frankly garbage and
like you know whatever
um what i think is interesting though is
if you say okay like that is one view of
the world and uh probably more right
than wrong in terms of bitcoin having
immense value
kind of moving forward but there's also
this
like kind of thought process of wait a
second there's a whole bunch of
financial engineering and craziness
going on here
if you're a pure capitalist and you say
i have no emotional connection
whatsoever to any asset
uh you can make a lot of money right and
drive a lot of returns so yeah if you
almost come out like from a hedge fund
perspective where is fund says
i don't care what the ass said it's all
numbers on the screen and basically i'm
just looking for things i can buy low
that go up and then i can sell higher
and you know make a return that seems to
be
the people who are thriving in this
environment yeah and
you know they're sort of i know i've
retweeted this a number of times
although it's not actually my
quote i say group cms uh
it's a cool firm i who
i coined this but you know sort of do
you want to be right or do you want to
make money
and like you know there's sort of this
thought of like all right
you can use your words you can say
whatever you want you know
and and i'll be here making money
because i'm gonna go yield farm
and you're not gonna yield farm and like
you know we'll see who wins
i know what winning means but i've
guessed but who's gonna end up with more
money
you know that that's sort of like maybe
what you're getting at there which is
like
put aside all the like moralizing and
all the philosophical
aspects of in the projections and just
say like can you make money yield
farming
the answer is yes you can make money you
make a lot you don't have to lose a lot
i mean it's
you know if you just yield farm scams
then you're just gonna lose all your
money
and um if you don't understand that
tokens
can crash and that their prices can move
even if they're not scammed
then you're gonna end up yield farming
and all the pools are probably gonna
crash
so it's not like you can only make money
doing it
but there are were ways that were
actually just not that risky
and so how much money can be put to work
in these strategies
right there there's a lot of people who
you know kind of created nutritional
wall street world and they say hey if i
can't put you know 50 million dollars
into the trade then it doesn't matter or
hundreds of millions of dollars
uh my understanding is you can't do that
but you also can do more than you know
ten thousand dollars and so kind of talk
through your experience with how much
capital can actually go into some of
these trades yeah it's a really
interesting question and it's really
different for some of them than others
you find a new project that is sort of
nothing in it and like if you put in a
million dollars you'll double
the total amount of money in it you'll
have all the returns and no one's going
to be there to buy the tokens you're
farming
so some of them the answer is you can
put 10 000 in and if you do a whole lot
more than that
you're you're just killing your return
like there's you know
um others you know difference or
different sizes
um and sort of what you should be
thinking is
a combination of two things first um
how much yield in dollars is being
handed out
not in percent but in dollars right if
someone's handing out
one million dollars total of yield ever
there's just a limit to how big you can
do that trade right
if other people are doing it to you all
fighting over that like
you're not gonna have a trillion dollars
at work trying to do that
if someone's giving out a billion
dollars of yield
i mean it's worth tying up a lot of
capital to get that
um the other way to think about is just
like how big is the world doing this
how much impact will i have doing it how
much liquidity will there be
in this token efforts mining can i sell
it
not that you necessarily will sell it
but can you sell this earth the ultimate
truth of like
is it real money right if you're getting
all this yield but you can't sell the
yield
sort of assigned maybe the yields fake
but if you could sell it then even if
you don't maybe it's kind of real
um and so anyway to answer your question
on the low side almost none for some of
these on the high side
well you sort of look at the numbers and
there's a lot of different numbers you
can look at
one of them right you can look at the
sushi swap migration
and how many funds moved with it how
many funds accrued to how many moved
back
it's not clear exactly what the right
number to use but they're all the same
order of magnitude
you look at how many funds got locked up
and compound at its peak
when it was like the only one doing this
um you can look at how much is in curve
i mean there's a lot of versions of this
if you look the biggest ones out there
and the number is about a billion
that's about how big the world can do
this probably more probably a few
billion dollars worth
of funds um and it sort of has to be
that big
because it's been like a billion dollars
handed out and
if you could have gotten all of that for
like a hundred million dollars that's
like a ridiculously good trade i mean
there's a lot of ridiculously good
trades but 10xing in a month is pretty
good
um and and so you say okay but you
couldn't actually put that much at work
right
like come on no none
i don't know i think any kenny you could
it's big
it's really big it's now again not
everything right like
only a few of these pools
you described like okay there's
something with ten thousand dollars from
what you've seen like
and you don't have to use names but just
like right what's the biggest single
opportunity from a size stamp what
you've seen yeah i
single pool billion dollars um it's that
that's about the biggest they've gotten
you know if you look at how much dye
was being and you had many hundreds of
millions of dye
in compound at one point you had
hundreds of millions of dollars of
fat in compound at one point um
you had uh you know you've had a billion
dollars in sushi swap you said a billion
dollars in curve
um uh balancer had hundreds of millions
of dollars yield farming
um yeah i think like a billion's about
as big as
the biggest single pool has gotten now
obviously put another billion in there
you're crushing the market
but i you know if the question is like
could you put 50 million dollars to work
yield farming
yeah the answer is yes you could okay uh
you're saying that with a smirk on your
face so i won't ask any questions
but uh let's talk about sushi swap uh
yeah
absolutely like this to me is like the
epitome of
just app you know chaos and crypto oh
yeah
in every positive way and every negative
way combined
in one thing um tell us kind of just
your perspective
of what's played out so far oh it's been
a [ __ ] soap opera i mean it's it's
insane
um it's i i mean and i thought that i'd
seen some insane things but this is so
much weirder
um so yeah it it was one of the
the yield farming pools they did their
yield farming on on
unit swap and i think they kind of did
two things that other yield farming
didn't do
um one thing is they chose a really good
thing
to yield farm um most sealed farming is
not done on uniswab
which is weird if you think about it
because
what product is the most used product in
d5
like it's unit swap what product
would you guess would be the highest
revenue product in d58
well not uniform says and turned on
revenue but if you turned on revenue
then maybe you swap right like exchanges
and it sort of fits high volume it's an
exchange
um i think it's like an underrated point
that like you know if you look at what
like
like curve has maximized the hell out of
their position
and they've done an amazing job doing
what they are what there is a stable
coin to stable coin liquidity pool
that's like not an incredibly high
grossing field in crypto in general
right like
you know they've done amazingly given
that that's that's sort of like what
they've done so far
um but all right so first of all the old
farming unit swap yeah okay that that
seems like enticing
and the second thing that they did was
they had this cool idea
well some people think it's blasphemous
somebody thinks it's awesome
whatever um it's whatever you think it's
potentially powerful
which is um well
if your goal is to
[Music]
incentivize usage and to kind of
get a user base and grow it out
what easier place to do that than on a
current version of the product
so what it did was it started out not by
building sushi swap the exchange but
by just having people farm sushi
by using uniswamp
assert the natural crowd then to give
sushi to and then to fork
and create sushi swap another tax
um so it made a few interesting
decisions that i think like were
powerful if nothing else
and it it gained in popularity and it
became like
the biggest yield farming thing one of
the biggest buy returns but but
the biggest by prominence i think that
there's ever been um
how much of that is driven by uh the
meme and like the name
and kind of the like twitter you know
right
gift lords taking over and really
pushing it
well certainly some of it is like that
was definitely a driving factor
but i don't think it was the only thing
i think that was
it took off because i had a really good
medium to grow on which is like
you know something trying to become one
of the preeminent
dexes um and if if d5 is
booming probably dexes should be it's
actually surprisingly few of them
um it's i you know you can kind of think
about what you think sushi should be
worth
um i don't [ __ ] know but like you
come up with a big number if you make
the right assumptions
you know it's like it's it's not uh it's
it's not like it's obviously just a dead
coin eventually
um sort of backing a real product and
type of product that has potentially
high upside so
so i had a good substrate to grow on but
then also
um had great memes not the best moves i
think beast has better means but good
means
you know a solid a minus on the memes
um you know to go with like a solid a on
the product
and and so okay sure you know as far as
food coins go that's way ahead of the
curve
like the curve is like you know b and d
minus respectively so like a minus a is
really good
um and i
okay so it got huge sushi was huge she
was like one of the most trade points in
the world
i second most maybe caught up to
ethereum one day
i don't know it's like right around
ethereum level um and
uh ran up a lot and i whoever is huge um
and everything was uh i don't know
humming along is quite the right word
it's like a
sort of massive like volatile eye
uncertain kind of clunky thing but he's
big and growing and then i
then and and i surf was on the outskirts
of it
in that ftx listed it um it listed sushi
um and uh and i made farm some sushi and
um and then i
it was about to have the great migration
which is like this point at which
i sushi swapped the exchange the dex was
gonna become a thing
um it was gonna fork off for me to swap
and try and migrate people's liquidity
from
uni swap to sushi swap um and like a day
and a half before that
um no me the the you know face
behind the project one of the founding
developers um
i took the treasury
and uh that was not well received
and took the treasury for those that
don't know uh means that
all of the money that was sitting there
uh was converted into eth and like
took it personally right right and to
right and to be clear it's not the
um it's not the uh it's not like the
user funds
that were there it's the it was the
and it's this thing just doesn't exist
so much in centralized finance but it
starts the project treasury like the
funds to be spent
growing the project out you know so it's
not like they stole
all the users money that would be like
really bad yeah it basically was the
idea of
uh what was being airdropped was coming
out of a bank account
right and they yeah bank account so it
was
not something that users had given them
it was something that they kind of had
created but it had value it ended up
being
you know what like 13 million dollars or
something yeah that's right
was not uh well received that's right
um yeah it was very not well received
and
um the rules realized shockingly right
the
world realized a lot of things at the
same time the first was oh [ __ ]
um the second was oh we probably should
have had
a more in-depth conversation about what
the purpose of this
was the dev fund the treasury like sort
of you know
pool of stuff to grow the platform what
it was and whose it was
and maybe we should have rushed to get a
multi-sig controller fix it's just
nomi's
sig but also maybe rather than
rushing to at least we should have like
clarified the ground rules for it um now
there have been some
sort of informal verification of rough
ground rules
and it is not exactly adhering to them
like this is
not what anyone had thought was was sort
of gonna happen or
or communicated at all and so
it was i i mean sushi crashed
hard the market crashed hard
um and i
the community was was furious nomi
seemed a little
confused i think like
certainly reading nomi's twitter like
if you take it at face value like they
were not expecting the backlash that
they got
um i think they should have been
expecting but they were not and
um and uh and sushi is always sort of
like
nearly dead and it's weird like sort of
it was all it all kept going on as it
had before except
the token had crashed and never had lost
their confidence in the founder and the
project and
there's no more treasury so okay not
great
um and it was like it's sort of amazing
that
there hadn't been huge
like rug polls or
thefts in defy so far that like none of
these platforms had lost the billion
dollars in them um
but still you know 14 million that's not
nothing you know that that's real money
there
and i i and
that was uh yeah it sort of
sushi went from the hottest project in
crypto to
uh toxic in you know an hour
all right so when all this happens uh i
was not paying
a lot of attention then all of a sudden
when it started to like
really really go up people started
tweeting it at me so i kind of spent my
obligatory like you know 20 minutes
googling okay
i kind of sort of understand it just
enough to to know what
bucket to put it in mentally but didn't
really go deep on it
and then all of a sudden when uh the
treasury was taken
literally my feed was just filled with
anger
hate laughing i mean just every emotion
in the world coming from different
people
uh the i told you so crowd the somebody
stole my money because i don't
understand what actually happened crowd
the
you know the token went down yeah i mean
just everything uh
and so i was like okay that's probably
not a good development for uh for
a lot of people um and then i don't know
24 hours later uh somebody tweets at me
and says
hey it's been transferred as a project
to you and i was like wait what is going
on so kind of how did that happen and
what exactly happened i guess
yeah um that was uh that was pretty
pretty [ __ ] wild so um
yeah i was uh i mean i
i like many people were not excited
about the developments with the treasury
i think i was like a little more
sympathetic than than some people were
just in that i thought that there was
legitimate ambiguity about what had been
intended
um not that i thought this was an
appropriate use of them
but that i i also sort of felt like like
legitimately like people didn't quite
nail down what what the plan was for it
and also that like nomi seemed
legitimately not
to think that this was going to be
perceived the way it was
like there seemed to be a real like this
wasn't sort of like him saying lullaby
you know this there's like a real
disconnect here
um but i but also sort of destroyed the
project
and also was the wrong thing to do and
uh and like you know it was also not
selfishly the right thing to do i mean
it's
made everyone force off is bad bad for
everyone like it's
and you know the honest truth is if like
he had never done that
and she's like worked really hard for
the project
and made it be a great thing and then
eventually was sort of like hey guys
like
like i think that like you know i should
get a percent of the tokens
i think people have been like yeah that
sounds right you know
that sounds like like you deserve that
and i and you could have ended up with
more than they
did so um so how does it get transferred
to you
yeah so i i wrote some some tweet
threads
expressing expressing my displeasure and
um
and uh you know basically like you gotta
[ __ ] transfer control this project or
it's just dead
like no one is gonna have faith in it
with you
with the keys like sort of like uh and
um anyway i serve like
that socks like that that's sort of it
for sushi um
and i took a nap and i was
like on a beanbag by my desk and
sort of just shouted out like hey
someone just tweeted that nomi said he
was gonna give you the keys
uh and it is as a weird moment um
but i don't know i come got up and you
know bolted to my
computer and and in fact so manhattan
tweeted a screenshot of nomi saying he
was gonna give me the keys to the
treasury
um so that's pretty weird and uh
and i mean it was like a kind of like
an even more bizarre twist than the
previous twist of him having taken like
like he sort of like you know was like
a really strong negative twist and then
an even weirder positive twist
um but i but yeah i mean
i don't know he he then did it like he
he said something the keys to the the
the treasury and um
and that sort of changed my weekend
plans
i mean you know whatever i i had thought
i was gonna do
it wasn't figure out how to do a sushi
migration
um but remember the migration hadn't
hadn't happened yet
like that still had to happen and it was
actually kind of a tricky intricate
process
and i mean we like i hadn't written
sushi
swamp or anything it's sort of like you
know so all of a sudden it's like okay
like i guess what's happening this
weekend
is uh that
we're gonna go figure out how sushi swap
works
you still have control right
uh so we are uh so the key was with
was passed and sort of like
technological control
over some parts of it although uh
you know as sort of dictated by votes of
community members
um but that control is transferring to a
to multi-sig control
okay sort of step one and that
transference is happening
maybe tonight um we we have everyone's
uh address now and uh
last i checked in we're preparing it so
uh that's gonna be sort of the next step
for uh
you know the next step for for sushi
swap in
sort of formally you know removing me of
control which is sort of important to it
because that's not it's not sam swap
and it's not you know i'm not meant to
run it i don't run it i don't like
it sort of like the keys were dropped on
me but it's that's not
i it's it's you know meant to be the
community's project
and so so you have no plans this is not
going to become the next
product line of alameda's to go and uh
no this is not and it's it sort of can't
be because
that's not like it would involve
fundamentally changing what sushi swap
is you know like that's you know if
you know if i like at some point
you know serum might create it or or fdx
or something
might create you know name a deck
something like that but serum did create
dex but
um i you know sushi swap sort of dropped
on
my lap and i want to be sort of faithful
to like what it was meant to be
and what people thought it was meant to
be when they
got involved in it got it
that makes sense and and so let's zoom
out for a second
um you have your hands in uh alameda
ftx sushi swap saga
uh you kind of have a front row seat to
a lot of things that are going on here
just so people understand kind of where
you see opportunity maybe just
talk through like on a percentage basis
of your time and mental energy
how much of it is uh on the exchange
how much of it is on trading how much of
it is on like the d5 world
just how do you kind of think through um
you know maybe the prioritization of
these different things and i'll use your
time almost as like a proxy for
uh of kind of focus and energy yeah
so um basically
um
it's i mean it varies right like
a week and a half ago the answer was
zero percent on sushi that's not a thing
um and and in a week it's gonna be
not zero percent on it but you know very
little
very very little it's it's like um so
that's that's sort of like a a you know
a little bit of a uh that's what's a
word like a
you know outlier yeah a weird musical
interlude in the middle of uh
you know but um you know i
i've been spending most of my time on
serum and ftx and so
i you know on the
uh you know doing doing sort of
the combination management and in
product vision and and things like that
and also a lot of low-level stuff i mean
you know sort of like a tricky support
ticket comes in and
like it's sort of not clear what's going
on exactly i'll often
take it um and uh
and so i would say you know recently
it's been
majority on serum
some on ftx and and then just sort of
general oversight
of of alameda but not a ton of uh
you know day-to-day uh intervention
got it where can people find you
on the internet and find out more about
ftx or alameda
yeah so i've decided that a good you
know i
as someone with with recently one too
many projects on their plate
a good use of my time is uh [ __ ] posting
on twitter so
that's where you can find me um i'm uh
spf
underscore alameda on twitter and i'm uh
i tweeting way too much
um okay so that's that's the easiest way
to find me and then
ftx is at ftx.com um
serum if you go to project serum dot com
you'll find a helpful website with
a bunch of links to stuff got it
uh i end the podcast with the same two
questions for everybody then you get to
ask me one
uh all right uh the first is what's the
most important book you've ever read
oh boy i mean be honest
like i don't really read books anymore i
mean i think like
i like fantasy books growing up but
they're
they're really vulnerable and and and i
mean i think that they're
i don't have that long of an intention
but even more that i think like
the world has sort of decided that like
uh
there are more efficient ways to convey
things often and i i sort of
agree so um i guess
you know i'll say rather than that maybe
some
blogs that i like uh which
are uh there's money stuff
um so matt levine's blog if you like
reading
about finance it's it's the best i mean
it's just uh
it's in addition to being super helpful
and useful it's uh
i completely bizarre and has like
wonderful anecdotes
um and uh you know i think that's
probably
uh probably my favorite you know
regular blog and then uh i also
like a lot of the like the 80 000 hours
if you're into effective altruism
um has a lot of good pieces coming out
um
about what you know you can do with your
life
um and yeah i mean outside of that you
know i sort of like
i should post on twitter and stuff but
but in terms of media i think you know
it's pretty much that that sports and
netflix so
second questions more fun aliens
believer or non-believer
oh god i mean it's like
i certainly would not assign a hundred
or zero percent probably to it
although some calculations will give you
a hundred percent sort of
i would not say like i i i don't know
how to think about this one exactly
and i definitely get like contradictory
answers like one way to think of this is
you just sort of like
are like you know you serve any
reasonable model and then multiply by
the number of planets
and you get that they definitely exist
like there's no chance they don't
um and then you sort of take a step back
and you're like okay but we've looked at
a lot of planets
and none of them have it like like
you're saying that any reasonable model
would have signed effectively zero
probability
what we've seen and then you say no it's
like there are these reasons that that
makes sense
i i have not thought hard enough about
this to reconcile it
i will say that i would say more likely
than not that there is something
um although that something might be like
seaweed
or you know yeah a variant on it or
more more likely something even maybe
even less like it but
i know i would say yeah more than 50
chance that there's some life on some
other planet although probably less than
50 that it's like
like us i think that's a fair answer you
could ask me one question to uh
to end this what you got for me yeah
which i
which uh which coin
have you most regretted buying in which
coin have you been most proud to have
bought
uh bitcoin by far
uh in terms of um
kind of most proud i guess the the
emotion of
proud uh i don't know if i necessarily
think of that as like uh
right i mean it's fine right yeah
but but bitcoin would be the positive uh
answer there
um early on uh
in like you know i don't know 2017
i actually don't even remember like
i i never really kind of waded into like
what i'll call the
the crevices of crypto that you know
like the super illiquid stuff
but uh when ether went from like 10 to
30 30 to like 100 in the spring of 17
i just didn't really have nearly as much
education
and knowledge and like thesis and
conviction and you know
all the things that like now i think if
you were to talk to me and say like why
do you believe what you believe
i couldn't have articulated any of it
right then and
uh to be honest there were five things
that like
i bought it and it was never big amounts
but it was just like i was more like
buying it because everything was going
up i kind of feel like it's like stock
investors today right like yeah
you just put money in anything it goes
on the index yeah um
and so uh that was short-lived uh yeah
but but uh that's probably the answer
it's just like there was all kinds of
it's like a coincidence you can maybe
and maybe not even remember now like
yeah and it's like dumb stuff right it's
like oh you know bitcoin's worth two
thousand dollars so like this other
one's worth you know 300 like
are they going to go is it gonna go to
three you know two thousand uh yeah so
it's just super unscientific
uh more entertainment than investing
frankly
um yeah but that's probably yeah all
right sam listen thank you so much for
doing this this is absolutely fantastic
i think people will love this
and thank you you've built some amazing
businesses in this space so well please
thank you
and we'll have to do it again in the
future absolutely